signori siamo arrivati all'apoteosi
siamo al traguardo di iscritti più alto
di tutta youtube italia quindi io
veramente ragazzi vi ringrazio
tantissimo ha comunque cambiato vestito
perché volevo dire questa cosa mi ero
dimenticato di dirlo nel video e lo
speciale lo sto facendo è cioè questo
quadro nero spetta questo nello speciale
6 milioni non è non è uno speciale lo
sto facendo ma è uno speciale talmente
grosso che non posso farlo uscire in
tempi brevi qui tra un po arriva spero
prima di natale però teoricamente ci
stiamo muovendo per far uscire mi ha
comunque nell'arco di un mesetto al
massimo ci là lo speciale 6 milioni di
rilascio alfa vigenti prima che è un po
più pettinà un po più buona visione
quello a giocare la partita solo
catricalà vecchia maniera mentre
chiacchiero con voi perché volevo dirvi
un paio di cose siamo arrivati a 6 6
porcaro 6 milioni di schede ragazzi sono
tantissimi 6 milioni di iscritti sono
veramente tanti io sono solito fare un
video speciale ogni volta che raggiungo
un traguardo così titanico perché
comunque non sapere neanche come
descrivono un traguardo che veramente su
youtube italiano non ha ancora nessuno e
quindi mi sento sempre un po come il
primo che deve in qualche modo spiegare
che cosa si prova sono veramente
contento di tutto ciò non so se è
scontato dirlo però è vero ragazzi ma
non sono qua per farvi solo dei
ringraziamenti per un'ora e mezza quindi
parliamo di altre cose
io ci tengo a dire una cosa molto
importante queste testati con merli dal
giorno 1 kg al giorno 220 chi da ieri
chi se ne fregano comportate con me sono
molto contento che voi prima o dopo
abbiate abbia come faccio a essere prima
di tuberi tale non sono anche parlare
sono contento che voi primo dopo abbiate
preso parte a questo gigantesco progetto
che è diventato il mio canale perché
molti di voi magari non lo sanno io ho
iniziato che andava ancora a scuola
l'italia andava a scuola quando youtube
era agli di amelie merito si scritti la
tua il regalo il canale prenditela con i
miei amici abbiamo deciso un giorno io e
altri 2000 dice abbiamo deciso di aprire
un canale youtube ma youtube ragazzi ai
tempi non era come hot come oggi c'e
cosi famoso così conosciuto non
esistevano neanche gli youtubers questo
termine è uscito fuori da dopo che io ho
iniziato a fare lo youtuber perché in
tante persone hanno iniziato ad
approcciare questo mondo è quindi
diventato un po più mentre per chi non
mi conoscesse questa cosa qua è sempre
molto strana da dire e molti non ci
credono il primo a non credo ci fu fabio
falso quando mi intervistò a che tempo
che fa sono una persona molto timida nel
senso che quando parlo con qualcuno
faccia a faccia io all'inizio
soprattutto ancor prima di fare questo
lavoro faticavo insomma a guardarlo
negli occhi ad avere una conversazione
normale in primis il mio lavoro mi ha
aiutato a sbloccarmi perché io adesso se
ci pensate non so comunque parlando
nessuno perché parlo alla videocamera e
finché io sto registrando un video tipo
in questo momento io non sto parlando
con nessuno che mi sta ascoltando sto
parlando con me stesso piquet non deciso
di pubblicarlo e questa è la domanda che
mi fanno in molti ma come fai essendo
positivi da parlare davanti alla
videocamera avanti a milioni di persone
perché tecnicamente finché non pubblichi
il video tu stai parlando da solo
io sto parlando solo questo lavoro mi ha
aiutato a conoscere tantissime persone
proprio fisicamente e quindi questa
timidezza poco a poco si è un po
affievolita e mi ha permesso oggi di
essere una persona insomma migliore più
sicura di penn senza di voi questo
traguardo non l'avrei mai raggiunto
quindi devo dirvi che cosa per primo io
sono orgoglioso e per il fatto che con
questo lavoro io sono proprio cresciuto
come persona le persone che mi sono
state vicino sin da prima che io fossi
pari j lo sanno
sanno quanto io sia cambiato in tutto
questo tempo in primis i miei genitori i
miei amici stretti e tutto questo non
sarebbe mai stato possibile senza di voi
ragazzi perché voi avete creduto in me
dal giorno 1 o dal giorno 200
chissenefrega
avete creduto in me e questo è
l'importante anche due compagni avrebbe
dovuto credere in me però non ha segnato
invece ci ha creduto e liberi che il
crederci funziona la dedizione e quindi
ragazzi oggi sono successe due cose la
prima faccio il lavoro che ho sempre
sognato nella vita perché alla fine
gioca videogiochi la mia fiducia che
sono la mia passione da sempre è la
seconda grandissima che questa è la
prima cosa è la seconda grande cosa è
che il mio carattere insomma è
migliorato nel tempo e questo
entrambe queste due cose state rese
possibili grazie a voi che avete creduto
in me quindi ragazzi grazie per essere
arrivati con me perché non ci sono
arrivato proprio siamo grati tutti
quanti insieme che senza di voi questo
traguardo non esistere ecco non è come
non è come tipo vi faccio un esempio non
è come cristiano ronaldo che
è uno dei giocatori più forti al mondo
ha vinto un sacco di coppe però lui lui
le avrebbe vinte anche senza sostenitori
da lui è bravo basta se voi non mi
avesse guardato non sarei mai arrivato a
questo traguardo perché mio traguardo
siete proprio voi
messi insieme sei migliori script siete
voi uno per uno messi insieme che fate
il mio grande trofeo e quindi non è mio
e nostro
capitolo quindi io non mi se per questo
che quando ogni volta che faccio uno
speciale mi sento di dire ragazzi
abbiamo raggiunto questo traguardo
credibile non è che vede che vive la sto
vendendo della serie a perchè tutti
quanti insieme poi realtà la gloria me
la prendo io no ce la prendiamo tutti
perché tutti fate parte se tu che stai
volando questo video non fosse iscritto
a quest'ora avrei 5 milioni e 999.999
iscritti non avrei raggiunto via
trovarmi ma comunque ragazzi non sono
qui per rompermi le palle con questi
discorsi da sé le grazie grazie grazie
che sono bitar tassate i cabasisi dopo
due secondi
voglio dirvi una cosa molto importante
io in tutto questo periodo mi sono
comunque sentito in debito nei vostri
confronti
anche se mi scrivete sempre messaggi del
tipo favi ci fa divertire grazie robe
del genere ea me fa molto piacere perchè
mi fa capire che il mio lavoro non solo
è utile per me ma è utile anche per gli
altri perché dunque gli svagate magari
abbia fatto compagnia durante la
quarantena ma anche ai tempi tutti
questi anni che sono passati sicuramente
spero di aver allietato le vostre
giornate almeno questa è la mia
obiettivo l'altro era saper tirare in
porta ma meno male che almeno uno di due
sono riuscito a farlo ma nonostante
questo ragazzi mi sento in disparità nel
senso che rispetto a voi io vi devo
molto di più perché comunque voi mi
avete regalato una vita da sogno
una vita che mi piace mi diverte sono
tranquillo
e tutto questo merita insomma gol
degli avversari [ __ ] nel frattempo
ragazzi io vi saluto e vi ringrazio per
l'ennesima volta perché si traguarda
pazzesco e it ragazzi prima di
concludere volevo dirvi anche che ho
aperto il discorso che trovate in
descrizione dove potete parlare
salutarvi tutti quanti abbracciarci
insieme perché da adesso in avanti
abbiamo anche il nostro server ufficiale
di disco spero che vi stiate tutti
quanti che serviamo segno gli utenti
pure lavori tanto passo anch'io
salutarvi quindi ragazzi
iscrivetevi perché molto importante e
noi signore e signori come sempre ci
rivediamo ad un prossimo io gli voglio
davvero tanto bene grazie per quello che
fate per me ragazzi
[Musica]